>> Laura: I'M LAURA INGRAHAM
AND THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
AMERICA OVERRUN.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS, WHILE
THE REGIME MEDIA HAS BEEN
OBSESSED WITH ALL THINGS TRUMP,
JANUARY 6, OF COURSE THE DRAG
QUEEN SHOWS.
AMERICA WAS BEING INVADED BY
MILLIONS ALONG OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
FOR A SENSE OF HOW THE REGIME
MEDIA ARE COVERING THIS,
UNPARALLELED BORDER SURGE, LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN THIS HEADLINE
FROM AXIOS.
BIDEN BRACES FOR POTENTIALLY
14,000 MIGRANTS A DAY.
WELL, INSTEAD OF BRACES FOR, IT
SHOULD READ ROOTS FOR.
THEY CAME FROM DOZENS OF
COUNTRIES >> Laura: MIGRANTS
TO GO THROUGH THEM FOR SAFE
PASSAGE.
NOT ONLY DID THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NOT REPEL THE
INVASION, IT ENCOURAGED IT.
THIS WAS A PURPOSEFUL, WILLFUL,
WANTON, INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO
OVERWHELM OUR BORDER CONTROL AND
FLOOD OUR BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY WITH
MILLIONS OF ILLEGALS.
95% OR MORE HAVE NO LEGITIMATE
ASYLUM CLAIMS BUT THEY DO HAVE
SCRIPTS THAT THEY MEMORIZED.
MOUTHING JUST ENOUGH OF THE
RIGHT WORDS TO ALLOW THEM TO BE
IMMEDIATELY RELEASED AND BUST TO
WHEREVER THEY WANT TO GO.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, THEY LET
THE TRUTH SLIP OUT.
>> WOULD YOU HAVE TRIED TO DO
THIS WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
A SPEAKER WE HAVE A CHANCE.
>> DID YOU COME THERE BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT?
>> BASICALLY.
>> Laura: THE REFUSAL OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO USE HIS
AUTHORITY TO STOP THIS INVASION
IS THE MOST EGREGIOUS ABUSE OF
POWER ANY OF US HAVE SEEN IN OUR
LIFETIMES.
BIDEN HELD ONTO HIS EMERGENCY
COVERT AUTHORITY.
UNTIL THE SPRING OF 2023 AT
LEAST, PROBABLY CONTINUING AFTER
THAT.
APPARENTLY THAT EMERGENCY ISN'T
BAD ENOUGH TO KEEP TITLE 42 IN
PLACE WHICH ALLOWS FOR IMMEDIATE
BORDER TURN BACKS DURING A
HEALTH CRISIS.
MATT EXPIRES NEXT WEEK.
THE ONLY CONCLUSION ANY OF US
CAN DRAW IS THAT THE DEMOCRATS
WANT A DIFFERENT AMERICA.
THEY CAN'T RELY ON ELECTIONS TO
THE STEADILY ADVANCES TOWARDS A
GLOBAL GOVERNMENT AND ZERO
CARBON OUTPUT SO THEY NEED NEW
VOTERS, VOTERS WHO ARE IGNORANT
OF THE AMERICAN TRADITION AND
WHOSE CHILDREN WILL NOT BE
TAUGHT ABOUT IT IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO THESE NEW
PEOPLE ARE AND WHAT THEIR
INTENTIONS ARE, WHETHER THEY'LL
BE DRAINS ON OUR SCHOOLS, OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, WHETHER THEY
ARE CRIMINALS.
AS LONG AS THEY ARE NOT YOU WHOM
THE LEFT HATES INTENSELY.
THE BIDEN FOLKS ARE SO BRAZEN
THE YEAR OR RESPONSE TO THE
BORDER CATASTROPHE IS TO MAKE
THE TREK EASIER THE MIGRANTS.
WHY ALLOW THEM TO WALK WHEN WE
CAN FLY THEM INTO THE
UNITED STATES?
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
CONSIDERING EXPANDING, NOT
SHRINKING ASYLUM CATEGORIES TO
INCLUDE CUBANS, HAITIANS, AND
NICARAGUANS.
THEY WILL ALLOW THEM TO BE FLOWN
INTO THE COUNTRY AFTER MERELY
APPLYING FOR ASYLUM ABROAD.
THE DODDERING BIDEN HAS NEVER
BEEN TO THE BORDER, WE HAVE
KNOWN THAT.
A TOTAL DERELICTION OF DUTY.
IT'S A HEALTH, ECONOMIC, AND
NATIONAL SECURITY CRISIS THAT'S
UNFOLDING RIGHT AT THIS MOMENT.
WHATEVER HAPPENS TO AMERICANS
BECAUSE OF THIS, THEY THINK IT'S
JUST NECESSARY COLLATERAL
DAMAGE.
YOU ARE NOT THEIR PRIORITY.
FAMILIES ARE SUFFERING, AMERICAN
FAMILIES LIKE THIS.
>> MY SON WAS STANDING ON THE
DRIVEWAY WHEN THIS GANG MEMBER
CAME FROM BEHIND AND WAS GOING
TO SHOOT HIS FRIEND IN THE BACK
AND GOT MY SON IN THE ARM AND HE
LITERALLY BLED TO DEATH.
HE DIED IN SURGERY.
>> OUR KIDS HAVE BEEN DEAD FOR
YEARS AND YEARS AND WE CAN EVEN
GET THEM TO SAY ANYTHING NICE
ABOUT IT, THEY IGNORE US.
>> Laura: THE INCALCULABLE
DAMAGE BIDEN HAS DONE TO AMERICA
AT THE BORDER ALONE, ONE THING
IS CERTAIN.
THEY'LL ONLY TAKE COURSE IF THEY
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO HURT THEM
POLITICALLY.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO CRITICAL FOR
REPUBLICANS TO STAY 100% UNIFY
HERE ON THIS SIDE OF LAW AND
ORDER, CONTROLLING OUR BORDERS.
SCHUMER AND BIDEN WOULD LOVE TO
SAY THAT THEY HAVE STRUCK SOME
KIND OF DEAL WITH SOMEONE LIKE I
DON'T KNOW THOM TILLIS OF
NORTH CAROLINA OR SUSAN COLLINS
FROM MAINE ON THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE.
AND THEN THEY LIKE TO ROPE HOUSE
REPUBLICANS IN SO THEY CAN HOLD
A BIG BIPARTISAN SIGNING
CEREMONY AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
JUST LIKE THEY DID WITH THEIR
SO-CALLED MARRIAGE ACT
YESTERDAY.
BUT CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM OF ALL
PEOPLE WITH HIS OWN WHITE HOUSE
AMBITIONS, I THINK HE SEES
POLITICAL TROUBLE HAD FOR THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
THE WORLD LOOKS LIKE PRETITLE 42
AND WHAT IT LIKELY IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE IN A FEW WEEKS.
>> Laura: AND THEN HE TOLD AN
ABC AFFILIATE "THE FACT IS WE
HAVE NOW IS NOT WORKING.
IT'S ABOUT TO BREAK.
I SAY THIS NOT TO POINT FINGERS,
HE SAID, BUT AS A FATHER AND
SOMEONE WHO FEELS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE SOLUTION.
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN PATRIOTS
OVER AT MOST 250 YEARS HAVE
SACRIFICED SO THAT WE WOULD
REMAIN A FREE AND INDEPENDENT
NATION.
ONE ONLY CONTROL OUR OWN
DESTINY, ONE WHERE GOVERNMENT
REPRESENT WHAT'S BEST IN OUR
INTEREST, FOR US.
BUT NOW FOR ALMOST TWO YEARS WE
HAD A GOVERNMENT WHOSE MAIN GOAL
IS TO GET YOU USED TO A LOWER
STANDARD OF LIVING AT A NEW
NORMAL.
YEAH, THAT NEW NORMAL REQUIRES
YOU TO SUSPEND YOUR OWN DREAMS
AND BELIEFS FOR A NIGHTMARE THAT
WILL NEVER END.
IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO US TO
AWAKEN THOSE WERE STILL ASLEEP
OUT THERE AND MOBILIZE FOR THE
NEXT ELECTION AGAI